on London Bridge passes by tackler
terrorists they pin him down one armed
with what looks like a stick they appear
to take a large knife off the attacker
this man emerges from the scrum
clutching the blade by chance he's a
member of the British Transport Police
in plain clothes this is the moment
armed policeman raced towards the
suspect two of them voter barrier
each holding a rifle without hesitation
they move into the bundle of bodies a
third police officer joins also
brandishing an assault rifle the police
shout at their civilian allies to move
out the way we now know the attacker was
wearing a fake suicide vest but these
officers could well have believed the
device to be real there's a heightened
sense of panic amongst the crowd the
plainclothes policeman runs back
gesturing to onlookers to stay clear one
of the helpers doesn't seem to want to
let the suspect go the pair are locked
in a fight look at the police officers
the one on the right is armed with what
looks like a Sig rifle the officer on
the left is holding a taser gun now the
attacker is isolated he's still deemed a
threat this armed officer from the City
of London police shoots him dead at
point-blank range two shots are fired
the attacker died at the scene his fake
bomb on display this all happened in
less than a minute
Deborah Haynes Sky News